how is the speed dating treating you
you know it's actually a little more
pleasant in my house i have to say
like uh makes it somehow takes the curse
off it than
being in some hotel [ __ ] conference
room it's kind of nice
uh i understand that completely uh
jumping into season two now that i've
seen the first three episodes
um let's talk about when did you realize
billy joel was going to be a cast member
uh it was in the break of season two
that uh you know because we we had this
kind of running
uh through line in season one that
huey was just a huge billy joel fan um
and it kind of kept coming up and and so
in season two
as we were mapping out uh huey's arc we
sort of realized
uh that there was a billy joel's song
that would describe every step of his
emotional arc
and i was like we should make it a
runner we should use a ton of billy joel
music and have sort of a
like a an emotional billy joel opera a
billy joel chorus if you will
that is that is through the background
of commenting on what huey is going
through
um and we had to get billy's permission
and to his everlasting credit
uh he was a cool guy with a good sense
of humor and signed off on it and
uh so yeah there's a lot more billy joel
to come
i'm sure he was very okay if you watch
season one
i'm like oh yeah i'd like to be
connected with a cool show yeah
you know yeah because we spoke recently
and did a really in-depth conversation
uh i actually want to sort of ask you a
few questions and hopefully you haven't
been asked
specifically um where are you in the
writing process of season three
we are uh halfway through um
we've been in uh we got to meet for a
month um in february
uh mid-february to mid-march and then
from mid-march on we've been in a
zoom writer's room um every day
uh i have my staff in one in some
virtual place right now
uh breaking um i think episode
six and we have scripts through four so
yeah no we're halfway through i know a
lot
about what that season is and where it
goes and um
i'm really excited i think it might be
our best season yet
well one of the things is it sounds to
me like you're gonna have all eight
scripts done before you start filming we
will
we will um how does that impact in terms
of are you planning on
shooting anything that are tied together
you know what i mean like are you
planning
it's called black shooting right um we
are actually the plan
for this upcoming season is to
shoot um two episodes
together you know blended together in
one block
you know uh uh it's it's 15 days per
episode so this would be 30 days
of shooting episode 1 and 2 for example
together
so when you're in the same location in
episode one and episode two you just
stay at that location and
shoot out both episodes um and so one
and two and then three and four and then
five and six
and seven and eight so four blocks of of
30-day
shoots um is the plan uh
which i think one is more efficient
but two in a coved world
you know who knows what it's going to
look like and the idea of returning the
locations over and over again seems
almost impossible
so part of it is also a reaction to that
you previously told me that you had a
few extra days to shoot each episode
of season two but now with season three
you're getting another three days
or episode to shoot which basically
means more money more time
um are you already using that in the
writer's room like oh we're gonna have
more money and more time
yeah i mean no it's a i think it's about
the size
of what season two was the truth was is
they gave us 12 days in season two we
took
15 days per episode in season two and
season three is only a correction to
where
we were we're just everyone's now being
honest about it instead of
pretending that you can get it done in
12 and then and then go over budget now
everyone's agreeing what it really takes
to make the show
um so no we'll have 15 and no we're not
writing
we're certainly not writing bigger than
season two and um
part of the extra time comes from you
know we just
we keep trying to twist our characters
and uh
more and more intense positions
and and some of it comes from like the
bigness and
the vfx and everything but a lot of it
comes from
you got to give them room to breathe
and try different takes and not be
jamming on a tv schedule like two takes
and move on
like where you can have time to do seven
or eight takes and really explore where
that character needs to go
um because i think really for as big
as the show is i think the thing that
works the best
are those characters and i think we're a
real
actor forward show i think they're
delivering awesome performances
um and that comes through giving them
the time and the freedom
to to deliver those after we spoke uh
the story went on you know about jeffrey
dean morgan have you made more progress
no it was the only progress we made was
he and i
uh texted about like well now everyone's
talking about it
that was it that's it i mean it's hard i
want to manage everyone's expectations
like
he's on a show and we are living in a
coveted world where people can't just
pop
up to toronto for 24 hours um
we are trying to work it out i will say
i can say now now that we're looking at
it more seriously
a lot of it depends on a microscopic
virus
if we can get this virus under control
where people can travel a little more
freely
um then i think it can happen
um if we can't you know i
i can't get them to quarantine uh up in
toronto for two weeks to do
it to do a guest spot on a show when
he's on another show so covid may
covet has taken a lot of things away
from
the country yet another thing might be
jeffrey d morgan
in season three of the boys um i know
i'm just about out of time i am curious
though in the
because of kovid how much are you
possibly
looking at the scripts and saying you
know maybe we can't be on location as
much as we were in the first two seasons
and we need to write more
stuff that could be done on a sound
stage um i'm not doing it much
and i might be accused of putting my
head in the sand
um but you know the things they tell you
not to do
are our sex fights and crowds
and the boys is about characters having
sex and fighting in front of crowds
um and i
am not so far in the scripts
uh pulling back on that stuff because i
think it would make the show
unrecognizable as the boys
and it's my job as the producer is to
figure out ways
that we don't have to creatively
compromise maybe we have to compromise
with production
and and find ways creative ways to solve
our problems but i
i need to deliver a show that no one
tells the difference between season two
and three
and that it doesn't suddenly feel like a
smaller more insular show
um because we're not shooting till
january i
again maybe foolishly i'm hoping that
just a few
things break our way you know like we
get
testing you know plentiful testing out
there
you know even that's a game changer like
if we can get
if we can test everybody at the door
walking into the sound stage
we could do the show um and do it in the
way that we've always done it the
it's just that there that doesn't exist
right now you can't just
you know give everyone a nasal swab at
the door and tell them whether they have
coveted that day or not and that's what
we need
um so it's it's my hope that by january
we have something similar to that